Щиро вітаємо вас ця програма У фокусі
європові телекомпанії Deutsche Welle
атаки Росії на Україну знову посилюється
російські війська закидають країну
ракетами в багатьох областях
повідомляють про руйнування та загиблих
російська ракета вважають в Україні
передусім цивільні цілі
президент росії Путін назвав ці обстріли
відплатою зокрема за вибух на мосту що
з'єднує Росію з анексованим Кримом
однак Хто відповідає не за цю диверсію
невідомо
під час російсько-ракетного обстрілу
загинули не лише мешканці української
столиці Києва
було зруйновано численні житлові будинки
а також пошкоджено важливу
інфраструктуру як од гідро та
електростанції
для багатьох українців шок від
нещодавних руйнувань посилюється
зростанням занепокоєння щодо найближчих
місяців оскільки попереду важка зима все
більше людей залишається без опалення та
гарячої води
Італія на порозі історичної зміни уряду
джорджією Мелані на чолі прав
популістської коаліції вперше
прем'єр-міністром може стати жінка
переможниця виборів Мелані ще під час
виборчої кампанії оголосили що виступає
за дуже консервативну сімейну політику
вона постійно різко критикувала
лгбт-спільноту
для Моніки та Марії з півдня Італії
перемога Мелані та її постфашистської
партії є кошмаром оскільки вона загрожує
їхній сім'ї Моніка савока родом із
катанії місто на Сицилії
[музика]
її дружина Марія Каррерас із Барселони
вони познайомились 15 років тому це було
кохання з першого погляду незабаром
після цього Марія народила за допомогою
донорської сперми сина Пау а через 9
місяців Моніка у такий самий спосіб
народила доньку Мію
може скуштувати зараз і потім
чому такою великою ложкою
хочеш краще облизати мої пальці ні
Перемога на виборах коаліції правих
партій затьмарили сімейну ідею Моніка і
Марія бояться майбутнього
дуже добре поінформовані про те що
сталося І тепер вони лякаються коли
чують ім’я Джорджія Мелані вони запитали
у нас що може трапитись моїх заспокоїли
і сказали не хвилюватися
страх у них викликають виступи лідерки
поствашистської партії фрателі ді Італія
джорджії мелоні
на природній сім'ї ні
ЛГБТ лобі
сексуальні ідентичності ні гендерній
ідеології
так культурі життя ні культурі смерті
такі фрази відгукуються навіть під
вулканом Етна в катанії такі веселкові
родини як у Марії та Моніки побоюються
що попереду у них важкі політичні часи
оскільки попередньо державна
толерантність до інших форм сім'ї може
зникнути
джорджея meloni Man не лякає бо вона
завжди залишалася вірною своїй лінії
тому я сумніваюсь що зараз вона її
змінить
це не лише політична програма а й чітке
уявлення про те як має виглядати
суспільство і політика Я боюся що ми
зробимо великі кроки назад у всьому що
стосується прав меншин
але передусім обидві вчені побоюються що
суспільний клімат буде отруєний
агресивною правою риторикою
небезпека полягає в тому що багато речей
стануть соціально прийнятними
без наслідків можна буде ображати жінок
або бути відвертим гомофобом під час
виборчої кампанії Джорджія Мелані
намагалася представити себе як
помірковану політикиню але щоразу
пояснювала що вона визнає лише
традиційну сім'ю а інші форми ні
що стосується прав гомосексуальних пар
то вже є зареєстровані партнерства і
цього цілком достатньо Я проти правил
усиновлення дітей для пар геїв лесбіянок
не тому що я гомофобка як Дехто каже а
просто тому що дітям треба давати
максимум А це Мати і батько і стабільні
стосунки Як це вже передбачено нашим
законодавством
професор каримського університетуласа
пієнца вона вивчає політичні явища та
уважно розглянула виборчу кампанію
джорджі мелодії зокрема її політичну
систему цінностей те що ми спостерігали
під час її виборчої кампанії можна дуже
добре узагальнити одними з її гасел я
мати яхристиянка і я жінка це дуже
влучно описує її політичну культуру а
також культуру партій ми вважаємо що це
буде для неї орієнтиром коли вона
очолить владу адже в інших сферах
повсякденного політичного життя впевнена
вона пост фашисти могли діяти лише
умовно оскільки вони мають мало простору
для маневру в економічній та зовнішній
політиці новий уряд імовірно ще більше
наголошуватиме на темах ідентичності
меншини як іграшка щоб проявити себе
політично що це означає для Моніки Марії
і Пау та мії передбачити поки що
неможливо
сім'я вже визначилася із кроками які
вживатиме якщо ситуація справді
погіршиться
якщо ситуація погіршиться то ми готові
переїхати в іншу країну
бо пріоритетом є наші діти
заради безпеки власних дітей заради
їхнього благополуччя та їхніх прав ми
готові залишити свою Батьківщину
таке трансформер
Моніка сподівається що Джорджія меллоні
схаменеться і не піде зворотним шляхом у
суспільне минуле знову обмежуючи права
меншин оскільки це сильно змінить життя
її сім'ї та багатьох інших італійок та
італійців
[музика]
багато європейців все ще застрягли в
рекордному літі не врожаї висохлі річки
та згорілі ліси Це лише деякі з наслідки
в екстремальних температур однак є ті
хто отримує вигоду від спекотного літа І
вони знаходяться зокрема шампані на
батьківщині знаменитого шампанського в
Києві сонце було особливо ласкавим до
виноградарів Тому вони роблять седріх
мусе очікуєно чудовий урожай
шампанського
адже на його виноград надзвичайно посуха
вочевидь не вплинула
для них Тут у регіоні Шампань на сході
Франції це найважливіша мить року
оскільки зараз стає Зрозуміло чи
окупилася їхня праця
сюди вкладено цілий рік роботи це кілька
днів збору врожаю на карту поставлено
все
останні кілька Ночі є навіть не міг
спати
Седрік мусе винороб у четвертому
поколінні переконаний 2022 рік буде
надзвичайно вдалим для його шампанського
гнилі немає це фантастика
подивіться в ящики виноград як ікра
це буде дуже-дуже гарний шампанське
чудовий рік
хоча влітку Шампань які Вся Європа
постраждав від спеки рекордних
температур та засухи
Подивіться виноград дозрів за три місяці
без жодної краплі дощу
виноградна лоза черпає вологу з ґрунту
завдяки своєму Довгому корінню
для більшості фермерів посуха є
проблемою але Лоза має коріння довжиною
від 8 до 10 метрів
вона отримує воду з землі разом із
поживними речовинами та мінералами
так місцевий грунт тут впливає на
виноград Уявіть собі як Це смакує в
кінці
Виноградарі щасливі але їм потрібне
терпіння
так давайте усе це кладіть у винний прес
мене три роки перш ніж вони нарешті
зможуть спробувати це шампанське і
переконатися що це справді шампанське
століття
поки що це виноградний сік
потім сік стає вином І лише тоді
шампанським це тривалий процес
всіх має дуже комплексний смак
освіжає рот і має аромат жовтих фруктів
дуже приємний смак
[музика]
відмінний урожай після двох поганих
але через це шампанське мабуть не
подешевшає
[музика]
перед усім цей рік урівноважить два
попередні
Минулого року врожай був такий поганий
що Ми навіть не змогли покрити Наші
витрати
Тому зараз ми не можемо знизити ціну на
шампанське хоча мені шкода любителів
шампанського
цьогорічного врожаю Седрік мусе
випустить понад 100 тисяч пляшок
Він продає своє шампанське по всьому
світу
сорт винограду місцевий стовідсотків
меньє урожай 2017 року
рік який цікавить
вона зі США і торгує вином
тарігати за збором врожаю винограду
справді чудово
порівнянні з минулим роком це як нічий
день
раз попиту нью-йорку дуже великий
шампанське набуває ще більшої
популярності в усьому світі також
завдяки маркетингу у соціальних мережах
що ніколи у світі не продавалося так
багато шампанського як минулого року
дві палети призначені для штучної Штатів
Америки
а дві для Люксембургу Сполучені Штати
для нас є найважливішим ринком після
Франції
Однак експортувати до Росії Седрік мусе
більше не хоче через війну в Україні
навіть якщо для нього це досить болюча
до цього часу Я продав росіянам 5% своєї
продукції тобто десь 5 тисяч пляшок на
рік
але цього року вони не отримують
шампанського поки все не заспокоїться
сьогодні Росія хоче завоювати частину
світу і ми можемо вже завтра вступити у
війну з Росією
то жодному разі Я не продаватиму їм своє
шампанське
із Росією чи без неї цього року
виробники шампанського хочуть продати
понад 325 мільйонів пляшок і це стане
історичним рекордом
[музика]
Одним із головних туристичних центрів
Албанії є шанжин на північному узбережжі
адріатичного моря на морському курорті є
кілька розкішних пляжних готелів однак
там де комфортно почувається туристи
живе також і багато сотень афганських
біженців вони виживають тут уже упродовж
року після того як слушні Штати
евакуювали якісь кабула проміжна зупинка
на шляху дослушених штатів чи Канади
перетворилася на тривали перебування в
режимі очікування
у житті джамшина акбарі все обертається
навколо баскетболу вдома в Афганістані
він професійно тренував жіночу команду
він і його сім'я могли з цього добре
жити
баскетбол Це моє життя він з самого
початку був моєю великою любов'ю свого
часу я був національним спортсменом а
потім працював тренером тренером жіночої
баскетбольної команди
жіночий спорт та ліби суворо заборонили
в останню мить джамшину вдалося втекти з
охоронним листом від уряду Канади
кілька тижнів він провів у катері і
відтоді застряг в Албанії Канада не хоче
його приймати
тепер він сподівається на візу у США Він
показує нам фотографії своєї сім'ї яку
йому довелося тоді залишити його
близнюкам трохи більше року вони
тільки-но народилися коли він бачив їх
востаннє розповідає чоловік потім якраз
зателефонувала його дружина
Я якраз даю інтерв'ю телебачення і
розповідає про свої проблеми
а саме самотність сім’ю всю цю
бюрократію
я весь час тут лише чекаю
впродовж Минулого року Всі казали мені
що Мені дуже пощастило
саме тому що я виїхав з країни що ми в
Європі в Албанії і ми на шляху до Канади
чи Америки
Але я вважаю що тут я найнещасніший з
усіх людей
рік тому американські збройні сили
вивезли літаками тисячі афганців які
тікали від талібану
на прохання американських гуманітарних
організацій бідна Албанія прийняла дві з
половиною тисячі біженців і розмістили
їх у пляжному готелі на морському
курорті шенджин вони повинні якомога
швидше доїхати до Америки але понад 700
із них все що там між туристами які
шукають сонце однак американська
обіцянка з кожним днем очікування
набуває прісного присмаку а нахета
хайдарі та її сестра багато років брала
активну участь у жіночому Русі в
Афганістані поки там править Талібан
шляху назад для них немає але вперед теж
поки не виходить
спочатку нам обіцяли що упродовж
двох-трьох місяців усіх афганських
біженців переправлять із Албанії далі до
Канади чи США
проте цього не сталося І ми Хвилюємось
Ми хочемо запитати про це в
американському посольстві в Албанії тож
просимо про інтерв'ю Там нас відсилають
до Міністерства закордонних справ у
Вашингтоні однак попри неодноразові
запити звідти відповіді Ми також не
отримали
ми поїхали до столиці тирани взяти
інтерв'ю у голови уряду Едді рама
Албанія теж поклалась на обіцянки з боку
Америки
я їх розумію але час минає
і Ми не вважаємо що адміністрація
случних штатів справді діє
Ми віримо що вони тут щоб залишитися
хай там що залишиться вічно в готелі
вони не можуть вони повинні
налагоджувати своє власне життя
але Албанія бідна країна і рівень
безробіття тут високий той хто може
виїжджає серед біженців зростає страх
залишитися в Албанії перші протести
почалися кілька місяців тому участь у
них брала також аханіта
адже ви самі бачите Албанія бідна країна
тут у нас життя краще ніж в Афганістані
тільки з точки зору безпеки більше
нічого
ми як біженці не маємо тут жодних
можливостей щодо освіти працевлаштування
чи будь-якого подальшого розвитку
джамшину тим часом все одно Він просто
хоче щоб його сім'я знову була з ним
Там війна
зараз половина населення Афганістану
страждає від безперспективності
безробіття та бідності
з огляду на це тут в Албанії таке краще
я б тут залишився
джамшит все ще мріє про нове життя зі
своєю сім'єю у США Але з кожним днем тут
в Албанії його Надія поступово вмирає
що ви відчуваєте коли бачите це
високогірне альпійське платок тут можна
було б дуже добре провести певний час чи
не так як гість ви навіть можете
піднятися канатною дорогою на велику
планину гірське поселення слов'янських
Альпах менш ніж за 40 кілометрів від
столиці Любляни але тут ви не можете
поринути в інший світ
Саме ці традиції визначають особливу
частину Європи це була програма У фокусі
Європи
за вашу цікавість залишається здоровими
і до побачення
українською мовою озвучено центром
медіа-ініціативу переклад Володимира та
Олесю Швед режисер Павло Тимченко так
читали Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та
Олесь гоян Київ 2022 рік
[музика]